[Music]
offers delightful activities and outings
round thee clock Professional Care and
exquisite housemade meals well I've been
eating everything is put in front of me
I've been eating all all Italian foods
basically and ice cream and ice cream
chocolate chip ice cream White House
Senior Living where residents feel like
presidents
all right I'm Dave ruin this is the
Ruben report it's time for another
Friday Round Table Extravaganza and
joining me today our two first time
guests uh first up editor and chief of
upward news Ari David and the host of
The Hoop chat podcast Emily Austin Ari
Emily I've wanted to have you guys on
for a while how you
doing good thank you for having us all
right let's dive right into it uh we're
just going to recap some of the
craziness uh of the week and of course
we've got the uh the big Iowa caucus
coming up on Monday maybe I'll ask for
some predictions at the end of the show
uh I would say the ziest thing that
happened this week is that South Africa
which is uh sort of I would say in
common cause or has had some history of
actual apartheid uh they are bringing a
trial in the international court of
justice or something like that it's a
clown Court that's what you really need
to know uh against Israel uh let's take
a look at some of the beginnings of the
hearing Israel has a genocidal intent
against the Palestinians in
Gaza that is evident from the way in
which Israel's military attack is being
conducted which has been described by
Miss hassim
s it is systematic in its character and
form the mass displacement of the
population of Gaza headed into areas
where they continue to be killed and the
deliberate creation of conditions that
quote lead to a slow death
unquote there is also the clear pattern
of
conduct the targeting of family homes
and civilian
infrastructure laying waste to vast
areas of Gaza and the bombing shelling
and sniping of men women and children
where they stand the destruction of the
health infrastructure and lack of access
to humanitarian assistance so much so
that as we stand today
1% of the Palestinian population in Gaza
has been systematically
decimated and one in four Gins have been
injured since 7
October these two elements alone are
capable of evidencing Israel's genocidal
intent in relation to the whole or part
of the Palestinian population in
Gaza Emily I will let you say it a
little more cleanly but everything that
that buffoon just said either was a lie
or a complete Distortion there's a
current there's a war going on they're
still firing Rockets into Israel they've
got you know 100 plus uh hostages uh
Israel's dropping leaflets telling
people to leave that like just it was
all Epic the idea that South
Africa is bringing this charge to this
clown Court I mean the whole freaking
thing can can you just talk a little bit
first though about how you got involved
in Israel advoc advocacy because you're
thought of as a as a Sports Chick but
you've become a huge voice in defending
Israel uh since October
7th yeah I mean of course I defend
Israel because not only am I a Jew but
I'm a human being the first and foremost
and when there's a country that's
consistently being attacked and their
existence is constantly being threatened
of course I believe they have the right
to defend themselves now what I did not
expect was this little reminder to the
world October 7th was the worst thing
that has happened at least as far as
I've been alive and it's a it's insane
to me that instead of the entire world
coming together to condemn a terrorist
group that just slaughtered dismembered
raped and burnt people alive and then
took civilians as hostages instead of
condemning them the world is now siding
with them and arguing basically they
have feelings too and now um
categorizing them as Freedom Fighters so
why have I become an Israel advocate
because it's mindboggling to me that
anyone could stand against Israel so
what I'm trying to do is share the truth
now in regard to this stupid idiot whose
name I don't even know from South Africa
he's contradicted himself so many times
within his own speech he said Israel's
Mass displacing gusin with intention of
genocide if Israel didn't care about the
gazin lives let me tell you something we
wouldn't bother displacing them anywhere
because they would just be collateral
damage in all of their air strikes him
killing Hamas so a that was the first
stupidity that came out of his mouth B
you can't say that Israel has genocide
sorry my airpods are falling out because
my ears are tiny it's good make no she
has tiny ears for next time she's on the
show we'll have that taken care
of South Africa is becoming the present
day country that's cided with Nazi
Germany in World War II they have now
chosen to be on the side of evil with a
very little understanding clearly that
it starts with the Jews it starts with
Israel but it doesn't end there because
a terrorist group when they say kill all
the infidels why don't you believe them
Israel is an example of what they plan
to do to the rest of the world and if
Israel doesn't take care of it I can
reassure you it'll be your problem next
so to bother them in defending
themselves and not protecting their
right to exist you're going to hurt
yourself in the long run because Israel
is the only thing protecting democracy
in the Middle East you lose that you're
screwed I can
promise all right we'll let you work on
the headphone for a second Ari my
position that is that Israel shouldn't
even at this clown Court these
International courts of Justice like
they're just they're just nothing
they're made up nonsense and that this
is still in the middle of a war it's not
like after the war where everyone can
look back and go okay we're mistakes
made here and there uh it's just a
complete clown sh do you think that
Israel should even bother defending
themselves at this thing because it in a
weird way it adds legitimacy to
something that's totally
illegitimate yeah well for some reason a
lot of people around the world think
that South Africa has some kind of uh
moral High Ground that we should be
looking at when really we should be
listening to South Africa the same way
we would be listening to a country like
North Korea talk about the situation uh
in Gaza and for example I mean right now
South Africa is nearing a failed State
uh it is pretty much a Dei regime on
steroids if your farm in South Africa is
too white they won't let you sell your
products out of the country uh there's
corruption to the max there where
hospitals and schools uh for years have
been having their electricity shut off
because uh the people that are in power
and it's a one-state party there have
not been able to take over and uh pretty
much be competent in ruling over South
Africa and so for Israel which really if
you look at if anyone who's been in
Israel understands that at least what's
going on in Israel it's a normal country
and it's functioning very well and uh
South Africa is quite the opposite so no
I don't think really anybody should be
listening or taking South Africa uh
honestly here yeah and by the way I
think Dave I want to add one more point
if you were violent and not condemning
Hamas very strongly and hoping that they
become eradicated on October 7th then
you best shut your mouth when Israel
defends itself and people I I I
emphasize the word defending itself
because Israel did not start this war
nor did Israel want this war nor did
Israel violate the ceasefire that they
had on October 6th and I'd like to also
add this whole thing could have been
over if they simply surrender and
release the hostages the whole world's
very very quick to start condemning
Israel but when you ask them okay what
about the hostages or what about the
fact that October 7th did in fact happen
suddenly nobody has a better suggestion
but they're very quick to criticize
Israel right it's well that's why I keep
making note that there are still
hostages and there are still Rockets
being fired into Israel there's a
current war going on it's like you could
end this right now it could end while we
are doing this show right now if Hamas
did what you just called out for uh in a
bizarre twist the sanest Democrat in the
Senate on this thing is John fedman
I cannot believe it but here is John
fedman talking about this ridiculous
South African clown court and now let's
also talk about that now we're talking
about genocide and now South Africa now
is now bringing that kind of a a trial
maybe South Africa May ought to sit this
one out when they're talking about
criticizing sit it
out it's a weird world we live in Elon
Musk saw that video and here Elon Musk
who is from from Johannesburg South
Africa that's right he's an
African-American he said he is right
talking about Federman Ari the the
Democrats have sort of lost their mind
at least from my position when it comes
to Hamas and everything happening with
Israel and everything else Federman is
now the most moderate San Democrat how
did this
happen yeah it's kind of absurd and it's
a mystery uh when you look at exactly
what he was campaigning on and the fact
of the matter is is that there's a large
portion of the democratic party that is
now afraid of the progressives and if
you look at the approval rating that
fedman has is in his own District right
now I mean it's nearing what the high
70% uh people clearly especially
liberals right now they look at
Democrats like fedman and they see
someone that is making sense uh as
opposed to looking at the squad and
people that are calling for ceasefires
they've kind of been disassociating with
those people recently also fedman was
clinically depressed and sort of we all
thought he was mentally ill while he was
a progressive now he's become a moderate
and seems like he can speak again and
everything else it's very bizarre maybe
he was mentally ill because he was a
Democrat and now he's happier because
he's found his truth I'm not a scientist
but that makes sense to me I want to
show you one other thing related to all
of this in San Francisco the hole
of San Francisco the woke disastrous uh
City Once once great City even 10 years
ago known as San Francisco uh the city
council voted 8 to3 uh to call for an
end to this war and a ceasefire and look
at these I may have to show you this
video twice because you really need to
focus in on these
[Applause]
people I just want everyone to look at
it again can I speak over this one too
just look at each one of these people
every one of these people would be
thrown off a building look at this freak
and this Weirdo And that gender your nut
bag these people would all be killed by
the people that they are celebrating
Emily irony is truly dead is it
not first that baby we need to call
Child Protective Services to remove that
baby from this I'm G to assume that's a
Woman by the way she looks as soon as
possible B I really think that this um
little party that they just threw has in
fact freed Palestine so I want to
congratulate San Francisco for being the
first city in the United States to free
Palestine lastly did they make sure to
call BB and Hamas and demand a ceasefire
now because they seem like they're
celebrating that they've accomplished
something so I'd like to know what in
fact they accomplished Ari what is it
about progressives that they can watch
their own cities crumbling I mean that's
what's happening in San Francisco and
Chicago and New York and Portland and
Seattle and they spend more time doing
these ridiculous hearings uh while while
they literally have drugs everywhere
crimes rampant you can't park your car
on the street and the rest of it like
the disconnect between their own lives
and what they think they're doing 7,000
miles away is
extraordinary well I think when you're
in that kind of mind space you're trying
to probably fill the void of meaning in
any kind of way that you can and for a
lot of conservatives in America I mean
we have religion and so we're focusing
on religion on Family Life whereas for a
lot of progressives that have taken more
of an Enlightenment route and walked
away from religion and a lot of them
which are atheists I mean when you live
like that you need to fill the void and
so they're going towards politics
they're going towards movements that are
constantly changing from one to another
because it would be kind of boring to
just believe the same exact thing and
spend a whole year talking about
something instead of having a current
thing that rolls out on a monthly basis
and so this is the current thing this is
exactly what they're doing they want to
participate in it it gives them meaning
uh it's completely wrong but that's
where I think it's coming from yeah well
said the
GU said I think the reason most woke
people are atheists is because believing
in God means you have a belief that's
something's above you something's more
powerful than you and bigger than you
and this woke mob they are so
narcissistic that they need to make
everything about them why is everything
insulting to them why are their feelings
hurt and they're too narcissistic to
believe that anything could be more
important than them including God just
shows you how insane they are I think
you guys both have you're both a little
bit younger than me uh do you think
there's something gener generationally
happening there is that partly because
of the internet and that it's just blown
apart everybody body's brains and
everything else that people have chose
to believe just kind of what's in front
of them than anything more eternal
sorry I actually think that right now
like gen Z the the younger cohorts of it
that are growing up with the social
media and everything uh probably for the
first part of their lives they were
looking at everything happening and they
were still thinking that these uh news
sites and the social media and stuff is
giving them uh the truth but I think
they're becoming disillusioned really
quickly and there's a break that's
happening so for example with uh younger
men and the boys they're becoming
conservative and they're kind of
rejecting everything that's going on and
everything that's being fed to them
meanwhile for the girls it's a little
bit different it's the opposite but
clearly there is uh something in this
generation where I guess the older
Millennials that have adopted this
wokeism to their hearts uh that it
doesn't sit well with them and I think
they're going to be looking for
something that is more true Emily can
you connect that a little bit to Liberal
Jews I mean a lot of liberal Jews people
that used to be friends with me that
wrote me off years ago I've gotten a lot
of texts since October 7th suddenly
going Dave maybe you weren't so crazy
this whole
time Dave I will never understand
liberal Jews in fact last week I was
fighting with a liberal Jew at Fox News
who was telling me how as a Jew I should
be voting for Biden and I looked her in
the eyes and I said are you insane if
you care about the Jewish people's
existence Biden's going to let that slip
right through and there won't be an
Israel or Jewish people to be there to
vote for the next Democrat
and she's just like well Trump's the
worst answer and I was like okay I don't
understand liberal Jews and honestly
it's kind of embarrassing to the non
liberal kind of godb believing
God-fearing Jews because they they just
twist everything to fit like again that
woke agenda and going back to gen Z
which is the worst of liberal Jews they
are the ones that lost the ability to
think for themselves because of social
media if something's cool on Tik Tok
it's cool in person too and no one gives
it any time or thought and then secondly
the problem is is like we all know this
but Tik Tok is showing you exactly what
they want to show you and they're like
poisoning Our Youth and whatever they
see they're so quick to believe without
actually indulging into whether this is
fact or fiction and suddenly that
becomes the reality and then lastly
another thing that jenzie including
myself has grown up with is over
catering to I want to say over catering
to feelings but treating everything over
sensitively like growing up I was like
don't want to play in gym my gym coach
is like too damn bad go run today if
that happens you don't want to run in
gym oh he's neglecting her mental health
oh he's racist oh my God he doesn't like
Jews and now he's fired and that's why
we're raising like the most sensitive
helpless generation of gen Z that the
world is now seeing we can't function as
adults this is the next generation of
Voters we're screwed that's why I'm
never sending my children out of the
house until they're 18 they are going to
live in this house till they're 18 and
then I'm just going to send them off
into the world and we'll see what
happens uh let's shift over to that
Biden guy who you mentioned uh because
obviously right now the main thing on
people's minds uh is this disastrous
immigration situation where finally
thanks to the internet as long as we
have a semi-free internet we're seeing
these crazy videos of thousands of
people pouring through our borders oddly
mostly middle-aged sort of fighting age
men and not a lot of women and children
uh Peter Ducey asks Karin jeanpierre
about just that High School in New York
is having classes today because the
building was needed to House people who
came into this country illegally so what
is the president's priority in this case
is it the migrants or is it the students
so let me just uh just clear this up a
little bit um so yesterday New York City
informed us that as a precaution uh they
would temporarily relocate migrants
staying at Floyd Bennett Field to a
nearby high school as of this morning
all migrants have returned to the
facility at Floyd Bennett Field and so
anything specific specific as to the
program and what decided to do and all
of the specifics to that I would
certainly refer you to New York City uh
for any additional questions so to be
clear what happened was our government
doesn't protect our border we send these
people to these Sanctuary cities and
states they end up the the migrants
these 2,000 migrants ended up at this
field the field was going to flood so
they temporarily move into a school
apparently they're back but either way
this whole thing is illegal and immoral
and everything else Ari these people do
you believe this is intentional yes or
no by this government
yeah absolutely it's a combination of
being intentional it has been for the
past two decades and now it's even more
intentional by way of incompetence
really a lot of liberals at the border
that are in those border states and that
have always been pro-immigration even
they're turning on this whole
immigration uh catastrophe that's
happening right now because they can
sense that even if the Biden wanted to
have some kind of control over it they
don't and it's just absolute chaos
there's no method to the madness uh and
it's quite scary for a lot of people
that are living down there it's scary
now in almost every major city in
America that has these migrants uh and
if you go talk to these migrants
directly they associate the Biden
Administration as the leader of America
who let them into America that is going
to uh put them into the welfare state
that's going to take care of them and so
really there is this kind of uh
optimistic view that the migrants have
of the Biden Administration and let's
also be very clear that from day one the
Biden Administration has been talking
about amnesty and so this is still a
long-term goal the Democrats are not
going to let go of this and so if you're
looking a couple years down the road
you're going to see a lot more calls to
give citizenship to everybody right now
and of course they're going to reward
the people that let them into this
country the people that gave them free
cell phones that gave them debit cards
uh and really fed them for not
contributing much to society here yeah
Emily did you happen to see the video
this week of AOC on Comedy Central
basically saying that the the solution
to an undocumented immigrant problem is
to just document them I mean that's
that's exactly what AR's bringing up
it's not that you do anything about it
you just actually document them and
congratulations they're
here well did she say it on Comedy
Central because she was joking or she
was being serious no no no no she was
being serious wow yeah well yeah the
problem thousand people in the last two
months cross the I saw a video last
night of so many children that were so
heavily sedated while crossing the
border and no one gave a damn to even
ask a question as to where they came
from this is who we are letting in our
country now I'm not saying there are no
good people that are seeking Refugee of
course they are so let's do this the
right way my grandparents came into this
country legally they did not sneak
across a border and now get free health
care too that would have been much
easier for them I'm sure but why is this
always America last why is Biden now
putting our security in compromise for
these migrants why are our students now
being Zoom schooled because the migrants
need our school as their facility I was
a zoom student in college college that
was the hardest thing I did not learn a
thing for two semesters paying $60,000 a
year to receive my education and I was
on zoom and now you're taking high
school students that are arguably the
most vulnerable students and you're
putting them home because you're putting
the migrants first that's America L well
a little bit of a silver lining I
suppose to this is that good people and
there are some good people in some of
these cities still like New York and
Chicago and elsewhere are actually
realizing that there's a problem on
their hands check out this video from
Chicago uh a black Civic leader who most
likely will be called racist by the end
of today calling out the nonsense of
allowing all the illegals into his City
politically having over 500 people in
our community would completely wipe out
any interest we
have are you aware that there are
immigrant Advocates at State houses all
over this country that's right who are
who are advocating for non citizen
voting in local
elections what if that happened here
that would change the mindset of what we
as a black community need to thrive here
in
Chicago that's a concern of
ours this is much bigger than the mayor
of Chicago or Chicago Police
Department this is an effort to destroy
our neighborhoods and silence our voices
even
further while I do agree that it's
bigger than the mayor of Chicago it
should be noted that the mayor of
Chicago did want Chicago to be a
sanctuary City just like Lori Lightfoot
before Ari it's good to see people
waking up like this guy's like uh well
this is a problem and we're not happy
with the Democrats that seems to be
pretty good right yeah just eight years
ago you had people like Bernie Sanders
that actually had uh a good way of
thinking about immigration and they
realized the more people that they led
into this country the worse it is for
American workers the more opportunities
there are for these massive corporations
to find people that are just willing to
work for less and so throughout the 60s
'70s you had classic leftism have the
position that
uh migration on a scale like this is
just terrible and you used to have like
the the most hailed uh activists on the
left go down to the Border when there
were illegal migrants trying to go
through and they would attack these
people and actually Biden has a bust of
one of these people on his desk in the
white house uh so he's clearly turned
away to the people uh and how they
thought even those leftists back in the
day and I think that a lot of people
actually will be changing their minds as
soon as they see the complete shock here
there was a chance in America that all
of this crazy migration chaos would have
just been limited down to the border
states but when that all changed with
Greg Abbot Greg Abbot that uh decided to
fly everybody and bust them to the
sanctuary cities he made the problem
affect everybody the way that it should
have been uh and so he's changed the
game here and I think people are going
to realize really soon uh it's time for
a change mayor Adams is now constantly
fighting with the Biden Administration
uh so is pretty much every mayor in the
cities they're trying to get more money
so they can do something about this and
really just put a stop to it so yeah
people are waking up right now I think
they're going to continue to I do have
to give credit to my guy Ronda santis
who did ship them out to Martha's
Vineyard before Abbott was sending them
up to New York and Chicago Emily do you
think it's is it cynical or just
truthful that in a weird way the
Democrats are basically like look we
have the black vote no matter what they
never break away from us so why give
them anything why not just ship a bunch
of illegals into the black communities
they're going to vote for us either way
and congratulations then we'll document
the undocumented and have even more
voters so as of two days ago they do not
have the young black vote at least
anymore which is a perfect reflection of
you are not safe in doing stupidity and
thinking you're still going to maintain
everyone's votes um I'm glad people are
waking up I'm glad especially the black
community and the Hispanic Community are
waking up because one thing Biden did
very well was overpromise and underd
deliver to these communities that you
know are marginalized or experience a
form of Oppression at least in their own
mind in the United States and they're
waking up like Biden promised us a lot
of things and he has given us nothing so
what incentive do they have to vote for
him again if he's not doing anything and
that's probably why he's letting all of
these migrants in because like AOC
stupidly said they are probably going to
grant them citizenship or at least
voting rights and these people of course
are going to want to repay the people
who let them into our country and vote
for them because he sure as hell has not
done anything for the black community
not done anything for jenzi not done
anything for the Hispanic Community
hasn't done anything great for America
truth be told and nobody has any
incentive but to vote for him so this is
now the Democrats Plan B what do we do
we can't lose this election boom let's
let the migrants in they'll vote for us
let's finish up talking about go ahead
Ari yeah there's one really important
note to make there and that like if
anyone should be concerned in America
about the migrants the black community
should really be concerned because that
the more migrants that come in here the
less the black vote matters I mean
that's just a matter of uh demographics
in America and how electoral politics
are played so as soon as you have more
of these uh immigrants that are going to
be voting uh a lot of these politicians
that have made the backbones of their
campaigns reaching out to the black
community they won't need to do that
anymore and that's going to be a really
bad thing for the black community so
they're definitely uh worried and if
they're not they should be right and if
if we're to believe that the black
community needs Social Services more
than rich white people well it's the
it's their community that will be hit
hardest when those social services are
moved to other people uh let's shift
over to to Joe Biden though because
apparently he is going to run again or
something like that or he's running
again or this sham is just continuing he
he doesn't do many sit Downs when he
does it's usually with Jill Biden they
never do anything live it's always
highly edited and everything else but Dr
Jill Biden went on Ma brzinsky show on
uh the televised mental institution
known as MSNBC for a little sit down to
talk about her husband and uh we we
enjoyed this clip so I see that strength
and that res resilience and that
steadiness every single day wow and he's
unflappable and when I look at the man
you know his Integrity his character has
not changed and he's unwavering he's
unflappable and I think what people
don't see is how hard Joe works every
single day that he gets up thinking what
he can do for the American
people the best part of that she goes
his strength resiliency and steadiness
and M goes wow wow um you think Joe
could do an interview like that where he
could just speak off the cuff and not
stumble and fumble and everything else
like are we just well past that point
and do you think they're just going to
hide him for the next year
Emily maybe his body double can I know
he sure as H can't he can't even walk
straight anymore she said Joe is
Unstoppable one strong gust of wind is
blowing him over what are you talking
about and then B why are you sitting
there it should be our president that's
sitting there and C of course this
anchor did not um follow up with any of
Joe's claims but me being a normal
person with half of a brain cell would
think okay uh what has Joe done for this
country just ask for an one example
she's just stating the most broad
statements that we know is not true and
she's not even coming back to her with
any questions or any statements other
than wow ask her a question how does Joe
put our country first you know she said
I mean I just spoke about how America's
last it doesn't even feel like Joe is
functioning as our president and now
Jill is trying to argue that he's the
best president it's just it's very
ironic to me and like we're smarter than
that don't insult our intelligence Ari
do you think a certain set of people
want their intelligence insulted I mean
I think that's kind of where we're at
like a like clearly half the country you
don't have to be a Republican or a
conservative or whatever but if you're a
Democrat right now you know something
every single person knows something
wrong with Joe Biden that is not me
being agist or anything else something
is not functioning I don't know one
80-year-old or 81y old that has a
full-time job me personally I have no
doubt that some of them do and are
highly functional and everything else
but I don't think he could run
McDonald's for a day and that's not a
shot at a McDonald's
manager yeah the poll show that everyone
thinks that Joe Biden is way too old uh
and I always like to think about the
fact that really him and Trump age-wise
are not too far apart but I mean Donald
Trump has more energy than I do and so
nobody's going around polling well is
Donald Trump too old people really don't
feel that way but when they look at Joe
Biden and this is bipartisan this is
both Democrats and Republicans they
recognize the fact that yeah something
is going on there uh and they like to
look at the people around him and try to
rationalize well at least we hope that
they know what they're doing uh but as
we've seen with the border and we kind
of mentioned a little bit earlier even
the voters on the Democrat side don't
think that any part of the Biden
Administration is competent anymore
right so by way I want to add
I feel very bad constantly bashing Biden
because in my eyes he's an old man I
feel like if God forbid someone insulted
my grandfather I take it very personal
but at the same time this old man is the
president of the United States and you
shouldn't know like a lot of Democrats
argue with me but Biden's such a great
guy Trump's not a good guy I know a lot
of great people that would not make
great presidents and him being a good
guy doesn't qualify him to be our
president in fact he's been the biggest
pushover president so maybe he's too
much of a good guy but not when it comes
to the American people so it's not about
age it's about Effectiveness and Biden
maybe because of the age is just not
effective as our president well as a
quot double sword here I wanted to
mention real quickly before we move on
from that there's actually a lot of
democrat voters that will look at Joe
Biden's age and they're going to
associate him with the old school
Democrats and that's like a really big
strength for Biden going into 2024
whereas younger people like Gavin Nome
that are totally associated with the
Progressive side of new democrat
politics that would really push a lot of
Voters away people might look at Joe
Biden and they might look at him and
think that is scile and might not be
able to do his job but at least they're
not looking at him like a crazy Democrat
that is pushing all of this crazy stuff
and that's not to say his administration
isn't doing that but that's just what
they see when they look at him that's a
great Point actually because I think
that's that's what's happening with a
lot of people even though he is ushering
in all of the woke lunacy it couldn't
throughout the government it just
basically couldn't get more woke and
crazy and leftist and and psychotic
somehow people think he's not like that
so that means something but I want to
just show one other thing here because
in that interview you guys know if
you're if you're losing it if people are
not believing that he's capable and
everything else what do you have to do
you have to scare the hell out of
everybody what do you think when you
hear Trump Republicans calling you the
Biden crime family
or I have one congresswoman the Biden
crime family sold out America marer
tiller green he's a liar he's mentally
competent um and let's not even talk
about what let's go Brandon means but
you have US senators holding signs that
say that Biden hard to realize our
country isn't it I mean to look at it
what we used to have and um what the
other side the extremists have turned
this country into I mean we would never
see things like that say 10 years
ago no no uh we would never see people
calling the president Hitler all the
time and all of his supporters white
supremacist we'd never see that would we
Emily absolutely not I mean first of all
the best part about America is the free
speech and for them to say oh we would
never see that 10 years ago maybe
because 10 years ago our country wasn't
in a place that's as bad as it is today
and secondly she said let's not even go
into let's go Brandon what that means no
go into it tell her what it means why
Joe Biden said it himself this Joe Biden
has said it it's so funny to me I mean
can't even take an interview like this
seriously I'm I'm being serious right
now because I know every single thing
was verified 300 times every question
was pre-approved 700 times and it's so
phony and fake I don't even want to hear
it and it means nothing to
me yeah Ari that's the other part of all
of this right as a new media guy like
just watching these things watching
these debates now watching these Town
Halls watching these interviews it's
just it feels like we're just at the end
of what old media was it was good at
some time it was necessary it was just
growing as our techn ology grew but
something ain't working
anymore yeah I look at the corporate
media now the same way I do as the
Italian mob back in the day they're just
able to get away with murder constantly
uh and uh right now at least the mafia
was cool and they ate good
food right and if we're even looking at
like all of the evidence that we have
now on uh Biden the corruption in the
family within Hunter Biden Joe Biden the
brothers really there's just so much
evidence that we've had uh that paints a
very clear picture of what is happening
and that there really was serious
corruption going on and the fact that
the media has been able to really make
it so that half of the country still
after multiple years doesn't believe
that any of that stuff is uh true well
it's really impressive and it's also
really scary did this anchor bring up
the fact that Biden son is doing cocaine
and they found cocaine in the white
house or
no um I didn't see the full interview
but I'm guessing it was not mentioned
the cocaine in the white house with the
cocaine son
yeah so if we're not going to address
like current events surrounding um the
president's son doing dealings with
Russia on doing literal drugs in the
White House might not be the most honest
interview surely M would have treated uh
Donald Trump Jr doing cocaine in the
White House the exact same way I I would
have imagined let me ask you guys one
other thing it was not scheduled but uh
because Monday is the uh the Iowa caucus
and people in our shoes love making
predictions uh Ari would you like to
make a prediction about Monday
yeah I first of all I I hate making
predictions because everything that's
happening right now is so unpredictable
but I would say that uh it's probably
going to be Trump's game there uh and
then we'll see what happens afterwards
but my overall long prediction for 2024
is if the economy is working and it gets
better and it might because there's
going to be a lot of Wall Street pushing
over and changing interest rates to help
Biden then we might just see another
Biden Administration uh if it doesn't
then it's totally Trump's game yeah I I
sense the same thing if Trump is the
nominee that we we end up with Biden for
a series of reasons Emily what do you
think I disagree with both of you I mean
in terms of Monday I think Trump is
going to bring the show home I think
he's going to be the star of the show I
think his lack of media presence is now
like starting to bring more attention to
him so it worked out to his benefit um I
think the's gonna like always talk a
good talk he's always really fun to
watch honestly I really enjoy him um I
just don't think he will be the next
president I think it will be Trump I
don't know even if our economy gets
better don't know if it'll get to the
point that it was when Trump was in
office I think the woke mob is actually
disgusting people and deterring people
away from voting left I know a lot of
Jews were a very small percentage of the
population but a lot of Jews who are now
saying you know what Emily you had a
point all these years and I think people
are starting to wake up why vote for
something that or someone who hasn't
done anything for your country and even
if he fixes the economy that he broke
that's not enough of a reason to vote
for him again so I don't I know I think
it's going to be Trump I mean it could
be wrong but I'm pretty confident well
if you're wrong we will clip this and
make sure the internet sees it that's
how it goes Emily Ari I thank you guys
I'll definitely have you guys back
really enjoyed this and for everybody
else we've got a postgame show in about
30 seconds Ruben report. locals.com
thanks for watching everybody I
understand that argument but also it's
like you're playing Monopoly with
somebody who you know won't pass go and
won't follow any of the rules and how do
you ever make any progress if they're
not following the rules got to send to
Jail uh you know there's that little box
directly to
[Music]
jail
post game with's